here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show all right we're back on
the Internet's now michael moore how
about making a documentary on how
citizens united is legalized bribery how
about it i lazy get working on that
michael moore yeah I make documentaries
about the things that we're not talking
about right now and we should be talking
about like what what are you working on
well I'm working on a film that's going
to
Medina has the terrorist ideology of
groups like al-qaeda becomes so
mainstream that they no longer have to
seek refuge in places like Afghanistan
well I think so sadly what's happened
since the death of bin Laden is I
believe President Obama had his own
mission accomplished moment when he
declared effectively that al-qaeda had
been defeated what in fact has happened
right is that they've become stronger
than they ever were under bin Laden
whereas under bin Laden they were asylum
seekers in Afghanistan what they are now
is the ones giving others asylum in
countries like Syria in the opposition
that come to hijack that revolution
they're controlling cities they had
controlled an area larger than the size
of France in Mali until the French
expelled them
it's an insurgency it's not just an
organization and that the phrase I often
hear that I despise this phrase al-qaeda
inspired terrorism no no al-qaeda didn't
inspire terrorism is the end product of
decades of this ideology festering on
the grassroots in the Middle East the
end product is al-qaeda but terrorist
organizations existed before al-qaeda we
had Hezbollah we had Hamas in Pakistan
there's many many organizations killing
people on the streets including the
Taliban and how much support do they get
from local population they ask the
similar sorts of questions that I heard
you asking here on this panel
they sit in in Iraq and they ask why did
half a million children die before the
Iraq war and when sector of State
Madeleine Albright was asked by Leslie
Stahl on 60 minutes she said you know is
the price for American fallen fallen
policy worth the death of half a million
children and Albright said you know and
I'm quoting her she said you know that's
a tough question but I think the price
is worth it and it's when they hear
those sorts of responses yeah they ask
the similar questions on the other side
so there's there's an ignorance on both
sides that needs to be addressed and
part of my work is attempting to address
that on both sides mm-hmm okay well
Richard Dawkins will this country
elected atheists as president in the
next couple of decades
I was kind of joking when I said that
Obama was definitely an atheist and
Kennedy was too I think they might be if
you think about it five hundred and
thirty four members of the US Congress
cannot all be religious and that's a
statistical nonsense many of them are
quite well educated they fight and burn
here on the panel
never mind the last bit I mean it
statistically it's an obvious nonsense
that 535 534 members of Congress are all
religious they've got to be lying and it
said if they're lying but it may be
quite a few presidential candidates in
politics you have to you have to lie and
half way I think this will happen in our
lifetime really yes again because 16
year olds 20 year old 25 year olds they
don't give a [ __ ] right about but I
don't know about our lifetime unless
we're gonna live very long because I
mean look at pot we thought I remember
when we were in college I'm talking
about the 70s we thought you know what
when we get to be the people who are
running things will legalize pot well
we've been running things for quite a
while
and it still isn't legal it's just now
past the 50% mark in the polls how long
is it going to be before the polls get
translated into legislation I believe in
this decade I think it's like really
yeah I think it's going to move like a
marriage equality where all of us and
there is a movement behind and it goes
so rapidly well we would have ever
imagined growing up that you'd have a
the most famous and prolific rapper
would be white and the president will be
black but get that what what is it yeah
one rather depressing thing about youth
in Britain polls show that a very high
percentage of British Muslims think that
the penalty for apostasy should be deaf
it's a much higher percentage for young
people than for old people older Muslims
in Britain don't think that young team
and that has very little to do with
American foreign policy I've come to say
of course that's what I'm saying so of
course I'll be there no one's defending
anything the American forum yeah I
certainly well that's that's nice
zatia and the ideology at railay but
also in it does demonstrate the other
thing that that older generation who
don't subscribe to those values were
also Muslims yes and they knew their
religion as well yeah in fact when I
joined these limits group that I joined
my parents and still do remain opposed
and in fact my mother slapped me around
the face when I was 16 and said don't
you dare go down that path which made me
go down even more but you know the point
is that they are still Muslims and my
parents said to me that's not the Islam
that we were raised on that we recognize
what radicalization has certainly taken
root with the second generation because
the ideology is new that's the
difference this ideology that I refer to
as Islamism has has stranglehold in
these youth and it's not just about
foreign policy it's a factor but of
course there's the ideological narrative
which is also another factor I see a
question I don't know the answer that
said one of this since 9/11 I've
wondered this the week before the
hijackers committed this atrocity they
were going to the strip club yes so and
and I'm thinking well how geez they were
like didn't that didn't they that's an
excellent question because is that these
guys no single terrorist organization
has at its head anyone that studied the
religion none of them are theologians as
we were saying earlier they're doctors
engineers whether it's bin Laden whether
it's the the guy that recruited me to my
grew these a doctor if you look at all
of them they have a preponderance of
doctors a net nothing against doctors
and engineers and scientists but they
have a preponderance 90 hydrous of among
extremists 19 hijackers were mostly
college-educated right well see it's
again as I said not religious nothing
good science it's about watching
religion is how you explain no allow me
to answer it's the black and white in
the Heritage not it's the it's the
empirical points imply they're highly
educated if you've got this religion
it's the poison yeah religion is right
walls are all part of everybody I mean
here's the question I've been asking for
thirty years the question I asked for in
religious religious it said I didn't ask
the Queen oh how could I be spiritual I
asked the question how could otherwise
intelligent people wall off a part of
their mind and believe in a talking
snake that's what I wanted to leave
their religion what I want to know
religion and Dogma generally presents a
level of challenges it presents certain
issues but what I'm talking about
terrorism is essentially a modern
phenomenon the idea the phenomenon of
suicide bombings and launching oneself
into crowded places to kill everyone
within Muslim majority countries has
emerged in relatively modern times right
so something extra had to have happened
to this fourteen hundred year old
religion - and that's what I call the
ideological narrative where did that
narrative come from well it was actually
what happened is it was used as a form
of resistance in the colonial times
because these are in the Arab world they
adopted post-world War One European
fascism ideas of a super state a super
people they adopted these ideas they
first became Arab socialism known as
Barth ISM which led to the Saddam
Hussein's and the Gaddafi's and then on
top of that they built it onto the
religion it became Islamism and so it's
this peculiar combination of modern
fascism superimposed onto religious
doctrines which is different to the
Islam of my parents and my grandparents
about the strip clubs this our natives
the kids who did the thing in the Boston
bombing yeah nobody saw that coming if
you had a relationship with those two
could you have seen it coming because
Westerners couldn't yeah we do this is
the work we do so when I was in prison
in Egypt as a political prisoner there
in the infant interesting in the same
prison that eventually held Hosmer
barrack
it's called Muslim Tora prison one of
the things I did is have a conversation
with a convicted professional bomb maker
and he was he came to Egypt to Train
Egyptians to cross the border into the
Gaza Strip to Train Palestinians to kill
Israelis I said to him the following I
said look the majority of these people
protested first of all the largest
protest against the Iraq war wasn't in
Pakistan it wasn't in Saudi Arabia it
wasn't in Turkey it was in Britain this
country you want to blow up second fact
most of the protesters were non-muslims
so what does that tell you about the
people you define as your enemy in fact
Turkey is a member of NATO that's part
of this alliance so surely you should be
trying to blow up Turkish more
the Brits who were opposed to the Iraq
war now first of all I kind of got a
look from him that kind of Tommy you
wanted to kill me that conversation
lasted over a couple of weeks and one
day I was in my cell and he came
knocking on the door and he said Majid
you know I've been thinking now this is
a guy who knows how to make bombs and
kill people he says you know I've been
thinking these people aren't my enemy he
said he was still a terrorist who's
still an Islamist is still an extremist
but he no longer believed in targeting
Britain I mean it's a stepdad ish yes
yes opposed oh yeah so you have why we
we need about a thousand of you out
there Real Time with Bill Maher Friday
night at 10:00 ask Bill and his guests
who are questions right after the show
at hbo.com